india junto con otras naciones en
desarrollo había pedido repetidamente a
las naciones más ricas y desarrolladas
que asumirán una mayor responsabilidad
en la mitigación de la crisis climática
al tiempo que ayudaban a las naciones en
desarrollo a alcanzar sus objetivos
anteriormente india apoyó una obsesión
por el negociador de bolivia diego
pacheco que insistió que los países en
desarrollo no deberían estar sujetos a
los mismos estándares que los países
ricos que históricamente han desempeñado
un papel más importante en la crisis
climática el primer ministro en adentro
modi durante la cumbre anunció el
compromiso de india de convertirse en un
país con cero emisiones hasta 2070 se
hará justicia de verdad si se ejerce
presión sobre aquellos países que no han
cumplido con sus compromisos de
financiación climática el ministro de
medio ambiente de la india vendería dow
preguntó en la cumbre climática como se
podía esperar que las naciones en
desarrollo hicieran promesas sobre la
eliminación gradual de los subsidios al
carbón a los combustibles fósiles cuando
todavía tienen que lidiar con sus
agendas de desarrollo y erradicación de
la pobreza el mismo señaló las
actividades sostenibles y la justa
climática consagradas en el acuerdo de
parís como claves para resolver la
crisis climática causada por estilos de
vida y sostenibles y patrones de consumo
derrochadores